We have a voicemail number and this is a very
interesting question that came in today.
Take a listen to this.
Hi, David.
Given that you're in the public spotlight
and you do a lot of critical commentary of
public figures, whether we're talking about,
you know, politicians or authors or speakers
or whatever it may be.
Do you ever have people that try to sue you
where they're like, oh, you're slandering
me?
You know, what you're publishing here is libelous
if you ever have people to try to silence
you in that way.
And if so, how do you deal with it?
The answer is yes.
And the details I've been advised by counsel
not to discuss yet.
So I've alluded to this before, that there
is a big story about this type of thing that
I want to tell.
And my lawyer has said he would not tell it
yet.
And it's I don't even want to say the specific
circumstances precipitating that.
But, yes, that type of thing has happened.
I have a story that would shock and appall
a lot of people in the audience.
And I hope to be able to tell it someday soon.
You'll know when I do, believe me, on the
bonus show today.
Pat producer Pat had a fiasco at 4:00 a.m.
last night.
OK, I'm going to tell you about it on the
bonus show.
We will also talk about ways different people
are dealing with the Corona virus isolation.
Infowars has finally been kicked off what
maybe was its last platform.
And we will also talk about the erosion of
deep literacy.
All of this and more on today's bonus show.
Join me there by becoming a member at Joint
Packman dot com or a patron at Patry on dot
com slash David Pakman check.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.